uh we have a Q&A session with Pastor
Rand skid and in this session he he
answers a lot of short questions and of
course it's quite brief because he's
trying to taple a lot of questions it
was really interesting and educative for
me because this questions came from the
internet different people ask different
questions I also asked my question but
it wasn't answered in this session it
was answered in the next session which
I'm also going to share with you I
really hope you're going to enjoy it and
if you like one please consider
subscribing and we appreciate our father
in Heaven you've called us to do a very
important work we want to do it well
first cleanse our hearts from sin but
Grant To Us in great measure the spirit
of truth that he may guide us into truth
dear God that the responses we give may
represent you and be a blessing to those
listening bless the audience father I
pray in Jesus name amen amen our first
question is why did Jesus wait until he
was 30 to begin his
ministry it could be that in the Jewish
system priests began their duties at the
age of 30 that's when he began the
duties it could be that could be one
reason why Jesus began his ministry even
though he was not a priest on the Earth
but he would ultimately be a priest in
heaven but it could be for that reason
the Jews began their Priestly duties at
the age of 30 so Christ began his public
Ministry at the age of 30 all right
thank you what are the fruit fruits that
we are supposed to produce according to
the Bible Well the fruits are listed in
Galatians
52223 but the fruit of the spirit is
love joy peace longsuffering gentleness
goodness Faith meekness Temperance and
verse 23 ends this way against such
there is no law in other words the law
does not condemn the fruits of the
spirit those are the fruits we're
supposed to produce and so when Jesus
told the disciples in John 158 here is
my father glorified that you bear much
fruit those are the fruits there are no
other fruits were required to produce
but the fruits by the way notice they
call the fruits of the spirit not the
fruits of the person if you set out to
produce those fruits in your own power
you introduce yourself to frustration
they are produced by the Spirit dwelling
within you through constant surrender
they are the fruits of the spirit only
the spirit can produce them in you but
you must do that from the inside which
requires the surrender of your life to
God
constantly okay thank you how do we
worship one God when we have God the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit now
we worship one
God in Genesis 1:26 the Bible says and
God said let us make man in our image we
have our which is plural but we have
image which is singular so fathers Son
and the Holy Spirit have the same image
it's the same Divinity it's the same
Essence it's the same God let us make
man in our image then you read verse 27
so God created man in his own image so
we have his one of the group in verse 26
we have our that's more than one one of
them actually did the creating because
verse 27 says so God created man in his
own image so we have plural in 26 we
have singular in 27 but it is always
image not images
image and so we have one Essence one
image one Divinity and we're dealing
with a subject that no human mind can
fully understand we must make that
admission whenever we discuss God the
moment you think you understand God
fully you're saying God is no longer God
but job 11:7 tells us can't thou by
searching find out God can't thou find
out the almighty un Perfection no one
can fully understand God you see and so
we dealing with the subject as massive
but there are evidences in the Bible
that there are three persons but one
Essence one Divinity one
God so we baptize people name of the
father name of the son name of the Holy
Ghost but it's one name okay three
persons all right so praying to Jesus
Jesus is not contradictory to praying to
God no but Jesus said pray to God
because even though they're equal they
have different functions it was Jesus
who came in human form not the father
not the Holy Ghost now Jesus in human
form was led by the Holy Ghost acts
10:38 Luke 4:18 Jesus said the spirit of
God is upon me he hath anointed me to
preach the gospel so he was led by the
spirit but at the direction of the
father and so God anointed Christ with
the Holy Ghost and with power we have
all three in Acts 10:38 God anointed
Christ with the Holy Ghost and with
power we have God the Father the Holy
Ghost and we have Christ they have
different functions and so Jesus says
when you pray say our father so he tells
us pray to the father now if someone
prayers to Jesus I offer no condemnation
I don't all I can tell the person Jesus
said pray to the father not the Holy
Ghost in John 17 when Jesus prayed the
entire chapter six times he said father
father father six times in John 17 not
the Holy Ghost father and so they are
equal but they have different functions
when you're convicted of sin it is the
holy ghost that does that that's why the
Bible says grieve not the spirit of God
not don't grieve Jesus or the father
even though they grieve when we disobey
but the power that convicts us is the
Holy Spirit and the Bible says don't
grieve him Jesus tells us in Matthew
1231 to 32 too you can blaspheme the son
and be forgiven don't blaspheme the Holy
Ghost there's no forgiveness so there's
separate beings separate
functions but one Essence one Divinity
one God okay just as far as we can go
all right M was Satan being thrown down
from heaven Revelation 12:9 literal or
symbolic Revelation 12 let's read from 7
to9 of Revelation 12 and there was war
in heaven Michael and his angels fought
against the Dragon
and the dragon fought and his angels and
prevailed not neither was their place
found anymore in heaven verse n and the
Great Dragon was cast out that old
serpent called the devil and Satan which
deceiveth the whole world he was cast
out into the Earth and his angels were
cast out with him in Luke 10:18 Jesus
told the disciples I beheld Satan like
lightning fall from Heaven it was Christ
who threw him out it was a literal
casting out of the devil yes all
right someone asked way the same God who
cast Satan Out of Heaven Can cast him
out of your life all
right one asks I had a child with a
nonbeliever and currently I'm dating a
Believer okay should I marry the one I
had a child with or the one I'm
currently dating I don't mean to be
harsh but I have to be blunt you should
not have been involved with the
unbeliever in the first place whoever
you are God loves you so do I but you
should not now you cannot marry someone
seem to because the woman has your child
or you cannot marry a man because he
fathered your child M you marry because
the person falls under the category that
God has recommended they must be of the
same faith not only of the same Faith
but other things must be in place before
you make a decision to enter into a
union that is supposed to last for life
you know we live in an age where people
divorce though it's a it's a sport but
marriage is designed for life and so you
do not marry her simply because he has
your child don't add one wrong to
another you marry someone of the same
Faith 2 Corinthians
6:14 be not unequally y together with
unbelievers what Fellowship have
righteousness with unrighteousness what
communion have light with Darkness it's
you don't do that yes you have to take
care of that child yes you must because
you're the father of the child but you
don't go marry her just because she had
your
child a child is no justification for
marriage must be according to God's Will
and God's plan in his Bible so do not
marry her just because she had your
child and she's an unbeliever marry a
Believer I mean a genuine believer not
just someone who sits in a Pew a genuine
believer who lives according to the
principles of righteousness all right
but as I said take care of that child it
is still yours and God loves that child
okay does God
laugh let's go to Psalm two I almost did
not answer that question but I thought
let me answer it does God laugh we go to
Psalm 2 we read from verse one of we'll
go to 1 to 4 of Psalm 2 and discover if
God lasts wherefore do the Heathen rage
and the people imagine you can re force
a vain thing while do the Nations rage
and the people plot a vain thing the
kings of the earth set themselves and
the rulers take counsel together
against the Lord and against his
anointed saying let us break their Bonds
in pieces Cast Away their C from us now
listen to four he he that s in the
heavens shall laugh at them mhm the Lord
shall them in yes so the Bible suggests
God laughs when the final judgment is
poured out something will come out of
him some expression that looks like
laughter now God does not make ton of
people but that ver he that sits in
heaven shall laugh at them MH sometimes
I remember my past sins and also we made
in the image of
God so the capacity to laugh yeah
perhaps exists with God as well all
right all right next is does sometimes I
remember my past sins and I really feel
bad thinking that God is still angry
with me what should I do you believe
what God has told you we must believe
God's word not base our spiritual lives
on how we feel because feelings change
with the weather the Bible tells us
clearly 1 John 1:9 if we confess our
sins he is faithful and just to forgive
us our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness now if you don't believe
that you are effectively calling God a
liar by not believing his word there are
many people perhaps listening to me now
who are walking around with a burden of
guilt because they have not accepted
aced God's forgiveness God has not
called you to forgive yourself only God
can forgive sin you cannot forgive
yourself forgiveness is what God does
forgiveness of sin you can tell a person
okay I don't hold it against you but to
remove Sin from the soul to remove guilt
only God can do that and God has
promised I will forgive you let's see a
beautiful passage in the Bible let's go
to Jeremiah Jeremiah chapter 3 we shall
read 12 and 13 of Jeremiah chapter 3
listen to these beautiful words and
believe them read for us my pastor only
acknowledge your 12 and 13
12 go and Proclaim these words toward
the say return backsliding Israel says
the Lord I will not cause my anger to
fall on you that's right for I am
merciful says the Lord I will not remain
anger forever MH only now notice the
word only do what
acknowledge your iniquity that you have
transgressed against so God is saying
look come to me and
admit I'm wrong only acknowledge come to
God and say father ah I stole that money
I am wrong forgive me Father I lied I am
wrong in other words as we say in United
States come clean come clean when a
policeman points a gun to you throw both
hands up God say Throw Your hands up and
say okay God you got me you've I am
wrong it's hard for the carnal nature to
say I am wrong and so God says only
acknowledge your iniquity that you've
transgressed against the Lord and you do
that he forgives you and he forgets
right but we don't forgive people you
see so we throw that attitude upon God
and we assume God does not forgive but
God forgive he loves to forgive Micah
7:18 he delighteth in Mercy and the
greatest act of Mercy is forgiveness
based on the sacrifice of Jesus Christ
whoever that person is God has forgiven
you believe it accept it and live as
though you are forgiven don't walk
around with the sins you've
confessed so our duty is to confess and
believe exercise our faith that he has
forgiven us he does not lie
amen next we have uh if God deserves the
glory and praise based on not based on
our
feelings will he still get glorified if
we serve him unwillingly yes God can be
glorified if you serve him unwillingly
now you get no spiritual benefit but you
can unwillingly conduct a Bible study
and someone is baptized God gets the
glory but you receive no spiritual
benefit you see because the motivation
is important to God the motive why did
you do it that's why many people will
say in the Judgment did we not prophesy
in thy name and in thy name have cast
out Devils thy name done many wonderful
works then will I profess unto them
depart from me I never knew you ye that
work iniquity and so the motivation is
important but yes God can get the glory
from service rendered unwillingly but
the person who does it unwillingly is
not spiritually blessed
okay if Robben was the only one who was
merciful to his brother
josephh why did Jesus come from the line
of Judah God can do whatever he wants
the question is if Reuben the oldest of
Jo Jacob's son was the one who showed
Mercy to Joseph and he told the brothers
don't kill him let's sell him into
slavery God didn't have to choose the
Ruben God does whatever he wants Psalm
115:3 but our God is in the heavens he
hath done whatsoever he pleased Daniel
4:35 but all the inhabitants of the
Earth are reputed as nothing he doeth
according to his will in the army of
heaven and among the inhabitants of the
earth and none can stay his hand or say
unto to him what doest thou you can't
tell God what are you doing God does
whatever he wants he is Sovereign now
the the the practice in the Bible was
the first born was the the the the
favored son you see the first born God
went against that Noah had three sons
God chose Shem as the line through which
Christ would come the oldest boy was
japheth not Shem Abraham Tia had three
boys Abraham n and heran Abraham was the
youngest God chose AB Abraham Isaac had
two sons and in the womb God chose the
younger of the two in the womb so we
can't tell God what God can do whatever
he wants even it goes contrary to human
practices so the fact that Reuben was
the one who show Mery to Joseph did not
obligate God to choose Reuben we cannot
tell God what to do God chose
Judah number four in the line of the
boys that were born to Jacob God does
whatever he wants and to add to that
would be to say Reuben was not sinless
either Reuben wasn't sinless no of
course neither was Judah but God chose
Judah he chose Judah all right and by
the way to to to extend that the priests
were to come from Levi Christ our high
priest came from came from Judah not
Levi so God can go contrary to human
practices and still be right all right
what is the right age to start dating
and is it write to date well in college
and or
university depends on your age you're 14
and 15 what do you dating for me your
child when God put Adam and Eve together
he put a man and a woman he didn't put a
boy and a girl are you with me he put a
man and a woman not a boy and a girl and
so dating is not for children dating is
for those who are on the edge of
adulthood for instance you know God has
given us the number seven is the number
of perfection let me go slow on this
seven is the number of Perfection now
the teenage years are seven 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 you have seven perfect years to
learn to be an adult and so my
recommendation I have no Bible verse my
recommendation is in your later teens
you can think of dating 18 19 when you
you spent some time learning what it
means to be an adult then you consider
uh day not 13 and 12 as is the case
people watch television and they see 12
year olds with girlfriend and every
child wants a boyfriend every little boy
wants a
girlfriend you must have some level of
emotional maturity you see and other
forms of maturity to enter in a because
dating is designed to lead to marriage
it is not a recreational sport are you
with me dating is not a recreational
sport its purpose is marriage so if
that's not your purpose you shouldn't be
dating but when you towards the end of
that trial period of seven years perfect
time to learn to be an adult you can
consider dating But as God desires and
guides all right and wisdom would also
call for how do you balance School in
this case University with your dating
well you have to
prioritize did I come to University to
date or did I come to study you
understand we must make tough choices
many years ago I counc in medical school
and I would tell the students all the
time when you're in medical school you
must put on your md glasses Medical
doctor here they are on this land you
have M that's Medical on this land you
have d That's doctor never take them off
so if someone were to say to you let's
go and play Let's go to a club you say
hold on you put on your glasses through
the lens of why you came you say no if
you take them off and lose your focus
you say yes to everything and so if
you're in school pursuing a degree did
you come to the university to date no
you came to study now a relationship May
develop yes but if you're led by God God
will take care of that but you're there
to
study and that is your focus and if
dating interferes with your studying you
have to give up the dating all right
prioritizing is not
easy because you got to leave your
feelings
out what's important why am I at the
school why I'm in medical school why am
at the University why am I paying tution
why am I paying tuition why am I parents
sacrificing so much why and you keep
this in mind all right MH okay okay next
one is um should teenagers over 18 think
about leaving the Seventh Day Advent no
one of any age should think of leaving
the S ad of the church if you study what
we believe honestly if you reason
through the scriptures we have a system
of truth that is 100% biblical don't
leave whether you go over 18 or under
six don't leave when the disciples were
believeing Christ in John 665 from that
time 66 many of disciples went back and
walked no more with him
and Jesus said to the 12 will he also go
away Peter said Lord to whom shall we go
thou Hast the words of eternal life he
stayed at the 12 Stage because of what
Jesus
said your church should be chosen on the
basis of what the church teaches not the
size of the organ how loudly the choir
sings how many people speak in tongues
what does the church Preach is it
biblical don't leave your the 7 ad
church and where are you going I don't
okay watch your ages don't leave all
right next uh spiritual prophecy
questions um first one is what elen G
white books do you recommend on the
topics of the Holy Spirit and uh knowing
uh known sins and their consequences as
well as overcoming those sins I
recommend two books one steps to
Christ if there were no Bibles available
on this Earth no books at all of any
kind and I were given a choice to pick
one book to live with for the rest of my
life it would be steps to Christ the
other recommendation The Desire of Ages
those two books are the ones I recommend
highly to the person who paed the
question all
right what are the unfallen
words is this truth found in the Bible
or just in spiritual prophecy there are
there's a hint or hints in the Bible for
instance Revelation 12 vers
12 therefore Rejoice ye heavens and the
that dwell in them War to the
inhabitants of the earth and of the sea
for the Devil is come down unto you
having great wrath because he knoweth
that he hath but a short time listen to
how the verse begins therefore Rejoice
ye heavens and ye that dwell in them the
Bible consistently talks about
Heavens in job 1:6 now it was a day when
the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord there are
clear evidences in Scripture that they
are inhabitants of other worlds that
meet with God regularly and Satan came
to meet with him as the representative
of this Earth because Satan came also
among them also job chap 2:1 again there
was a day when these Representatives
come so we have evidence from the Bible
that there are worlds where people live
who have never sinned okay and if we're
faithful one day when Christ sets up
this new world we'll be able to visit
them and this is literal not symbolic
we'll be able to visit them
okay and Ellen White says that every Act
is judged by the motive that prompts it
could you please elaborate what this
means let's go to Mark chapter 7 Mark 7
we read 20- 21 listen carefully to The
Words of Christ then we'll go to Matthew
12 we'll read uh 34 33
3435 we're looking at Mark 7: 20
vers say and he said what and he say
what comes out of man that defiles okay
now in other words adultery comes out of
here hatred comes out of here pride
comes out of here it goes from the
inside out even if you never do it
physically you've done it because it
comes out of here this is where motives
are and so let's go to Mark let's go to
to Matthew 12 let's read verse 33
that's Matthew 12:33 hear what that
verse say when we go to
34 1234 reads 33 33
M either make the tree good uh and its
fruits its fruits good or else make the
tree bad it's fruit bad for a tree is
known by its okay what it produ now read
34 brood of vipers MH how can you being
being evil speak good things for out of
out of the abundance yes the mouth
speaks what comes from here originates
here what comes from here originates
here read verse 35 a good man a good man
out of a good treasure treasure or heard
brings forth yes it this is the origin
this is where motive this is what
determines the character of an act why
did now for instance here's a man he's
wealthy he gives $1 million to the
church and all the church members this
amen amen they don't understand he just
wants his name on a plaque you see God
sees that and he gets no spiritual
benefit from God now God will use the
money the money is his but that man gets
no credit from God not because his
motive was wrong but no human being
ConEd and so the servant of the Lord
tells us in Christ object lessons P 316
paragraph 2 Every Act is judged by the
motive why did you do that why
but that applies on the earth you see
when there's a crime investigators
search first for a motive why did he the
motive will determine the the character
of the ACT is it manslaughter or
first-degree murder what was the motive
he came to the house to steal he
struggled with the house owner the house
owner had a gun in the struggle he took
the gun and shot him that's manslaughter
now if he came to the house with a gun
he had a different motive you see is
more than theft and so motive
determines the quality of an act and so
we keep the Sabbath for the right motive
to glorify God we return a tithe for the
right motive not so God will give us
money because God said do it to glorify
God everything we do what's the motive
the glory of God without exception my
good pastor all right thank you very
much is there a conflict between 1
Timothy 4:3 and Ellen White's teaching
on health let's go to 1 Timothy chapter
4:3 we shall read from verse 1 of 1
Timothy chapter 4 now the spirit
speaketh expressly that in the latter
times some shall depart from the faith
you can pick it up from verse two verse
two speaking lies in hypocrisy having
their own consci seared with a hot now
listen to verse three forbidding to
marry and commanding tostain from foods
which God created to be received with
Thanksgiving by those who believe and
know the truth Now read verse four for
every creature of God is good and
nothing is to be refused if it's
received with thanks giving for it is
Sanctified by the word God and pray look
at verse three again that's why the
Bible must be read microscopically let's
look at verse three again forbidding to
marry and commanding to abstain from
Meats which God hath created to be
received with Thanksgiving of whom by uh
uh huh those who believe uhhuh know ah
so we have a restricted population now
not the whole world because the whole
world does not believe so Paul is
condemning those who forbid what God
approves forbidding to marry and
commanding to abstain from me which God
hath created to be received with
Thanksgiving of them that believe and
all the truth you know the people of God
now when you read verse four for every
every creature of God is good Every
Creature means every creature that God
created for his people in verse three
not everything that lives verse three
puts restrictions on verse four Every
Creature means every creature God has
created to be received with Thanksgiving
of those that believe and know the truth
not just the whole world and so 1
Timothy 4:3 does not contradict the
counsel we have from the spirit of
Prophecy not at all all right
finally Why don't many Adventist
churches teach medical missionary work
well we don't know statistically how
many don't or how many do is just an
assumption the good person is making now
I would imagine many don't because it is
not studied and its importance is not
understood but you know in
um in her writings Al right consistently
supports medical missionary work Christ
did more healing and good work works for
people than he did preaching if you heal
me I'll listen to you are you following
me if I'm in pain don't tell me keep the
Sabbath get rid of my pain if I'm hungry
don't tell me L sing hymns give me food
and so medical missionary work meets the
material needs of people so that they
become more more apt to listen to The
Gospel a starving man cannot concentrate
on the gospel a naked man wants clothes
not prayer he wants clothes and so the
medical missionary work is absolutely
essential and the church needs to be
aware of that but no church can be
commanded to promote medical missionary
work and so medical missionar should not
be frustrated because this chch or that
church is not promoted do it where
you're able to do it do it individually
if you have the skill you do it
individually don't wait for a church to
tell you to do it because the church
didn't tell you sin you did that all by
yourself then you can by yourself make a
decision to reach out to people with
your knowledge and bless them but
churches really yes should promote
medical missionary work Christ was a
medical
missionary is the way to reach people
whom you otherwise would not reach
because all sick people is the right arm
it's not a gospel is the right arm of
the Gospel you understand me yes so I
support medical missionary work one
100% mhm is that it for today yes that's
let me just say to those who listening I
wish I could see you wherever you are I
really wish but I don't know where you
are but wherever you are the only
intelligent way to live your life is
based on Matthew 4:4 where Jesus said to
the devil man shall not live by bread
alone but by every word that proceedeth
out of the mouth of God live by this
teach it to your children a TI to every
decision you have to make if you do this
God will securely secure you not only in
this life but he will secure you for the
life to come I recommend to you I urge
you the word of God studied and obeyed
will produce in you the very image and
likeness of your savior God bless you
and may God put a double blessing on
your children my pastor I'm always happy
to be with you God blessed you and bless
your ministry you too let's pray amen
Our Father in Heaven we're honored
beyond anything we can deserve to speak
for
you let your spirit take our efforts
dear God and make our words clearer to
those who heard bless every person who
listened bless every family bless any
Ministry that may benefit from what
we've done and let our efforts dear God
result in more people coming to know
Christ more people falling in love with
thus say the Lord with the truth which
sanctifies bless every country
represented by those who watched I pray
remind them that the most high ruleth in
the kingdoms of men keep us under your
care take care of us father save all of
us when you come I offer this prayer
from my heart in Jesus name amen amen
amen if you have reached this far it
means you really enjoyed the session
just as much as I did because I the en
to now a lot of people watch this
channel but they are not subscribed so
if you're able to subscribe for me I
really appreciate and it encourages me
to do more content have a good day and I
salute you